das ist wirklich eine absolute premiere
zum ersten mal wird ein ganz normales
oder zumindest fast normales auto ins
all fliegen und jetzt kommt es zum mars
geschickt was ist jetzt wieder los mit
allen masc die ihnen mars chroniken
jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja es gibt so unglaublich viele bei
ihnen macht zu berichten und ihr
interessiert euch ziemlich für diesen
wirklich schillernden unternehmen und
alles was um ihn herum passiert alles
was er anpackt wird außergewöhnlich und
immer wieder verblüfft mit unglaublichen
ideen bahnbrechende rekorden und
innovationen mit denen so keiner
gerechnet hätte deshalb machen wir jetzt
eine eigene rubrik auf hierbei klicks um
die ihnen masco nicken los geht's
ja nur noch ein paar tage dann startet
der jungfernflug der falcon heavy und
das ist schon etwas ganz besonderes
es kam nicht ein wenig verwirrung darum
aber es scheint tatsächlich wirklichkeit
zu werden ihnen masken seinen eigenen
tesla roadster in den weltraum schicken
aber nicht nur den dazu gleich mehr es
geht um den ersten flug der falcon heavy
der größten rakete der welt die ein
neues zeitalter der raumfahrt einläuten
wird doch bei diesem testflug soll keine
nutzlast transportiert werden denn das
risiko wäre zu gross dass sie zerstört
wird dabei ist es erst vor wenigen tagen
ein missgeschick passiert eine falcon 9
hat ihre wertvolle fracht verloren den
milliardenteuren spionagesatelliten zu
mehr soll in der atmosphäre verglüht
sein
ob das aber tatsächlich so passiert ist
und wege spionagesatellit und wenn ja
was dort genau geschehen ist dass es
unklar
spacex jedenfalls schießt eine
fehlfunktion der falcon 9 aus jetzt also
schon ende januar eine neue
rekordleistung die falcon heavy sie ist
absolut rekordverdächtig kann man gar
nicht sagen rekord gewiss keine rakete
kann so viel nutzlast transportieren
also keine aktuelle je nach ort kann sie
bis zu 63 8 tonnen last in den weltraum
bringen
das ist immens bei der felke neuen sind
es 22,8 tonnen also nur ein drittel
einen mast hatte sich vorgenommen bei
diesem ersten test etwas vollkommen
verrücktes in den weltraum zu fliegen
und dann hat er sich entschieden es soll
sein tesla roadster sein
er gehört zur ersten generation roadster
und wurde 2009 produziert seitdem wurde
er von mas gefahren und jetzt wird es
eine strecke zurücklegen die noch nie
ein auto zurücklegt hat absolut verrückt
aber noch verrückter ist das was ihnen
maskin das auto gepackt hat die audio
anlage wird space oddity von david bowie
spielen und im handschuhfach ist eine
ausgabe vom per anhalter durch die
galaxis von douglas adams und ein
handtuch mit der aufschrift keine panik
ziel ist der mars und der roadster wird
für zitat für milliarden von jahren in
den tiefen des alls schweben so musk
wenn die rakete nicht beim start
explodiert meint erweitert man muss es
ihnen musk lassen er hat auch noch sind
für
zur zeit wird alles für den start
vorbereitet und es wird ein historisches
ereignis
die falcon heavy wird von der startrampe
staaten von der die saturn 5 die ersten
astronauten zum mond gebracht hat es
wird also geschichte geschrieben in
wenigen tagen wenn er kein video zu
diesem historischen ereignis verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein aber aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue in videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars da
geht es um noch so ein paar kleine ideen
von allen masc ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran